i want to play this for you is is this
perhaps the dumbest
and cringiest woke corporate virtue
signal of all time and i know that's
saying something we had oreos yesterday
you know oreos putting an ad out uh
about a uh an asian
kid coming coming out as gay to his
grandmother
nothing to do with oreos whatsoever no
attempt to even circle it back
to uh to oreos
well now another snack food has gotten
in on the action this is from the daily
wire it says the makers of cracker jack
uh of course the caramel popcorn snack
popular baseball stadiums and
prominently featured in the classic
baseball anthem taking out to the ball
game is receiving a woke repackaging
including a rewriting of the song with a
gender equality message so they have
rebranded themselves as not cracker jack
but cracker jill
and they wrote on their website
sometimes all it takes to believe you
can do something is to see someone who
looks like you do it first
it's in this spirit that cracker jack
proudly introduces cracker jill
a team of new faces showing girls that
they're represented
even in our most iconic snacks
i understand the need for this
okay i i can't i can't i'll never forget
the first time
i was in the snack aisle with uh with my
daughter and she saw the cracker jack
box and she just broke down in tears
she saw a cracker jacket she said to me
daddy does this mean that
that i can't pursue my own dreams
and i said to her yeah it does that's
exactly what it means
but now that they've rebranded the
cracker jill i can go home and i can
tell the news to my daughter
that you see they rebranded the cracker
jelly so you can do anything that you
want in your life
don't all women look to
snack companies for their inspiration
and motivation in life
well this is about to get really
inspiring because as mentioned they
rebranded the song to take me out to a
ball to the ball game to give a little
bit of a feminist
bent
and uh let's listen to that
take me out
[Music]
the
again
buy me some peanuts and cracker jail
no one can stop you if you have the
wheelchair less root rope
[Music]
is
[Music]
play ball
that's a tough one that's a tough one
that's eve that's even harder to get
through than the joe biden video
crackerjill.com you can go
now this is if they expect that people
are going to start actually singing that
at baseball games there is less chance
of that than there is that uh hispanic
people actually start calling themselves
latinx there's even less chance that
that's gonna happen
and i
i don't need to say it i know but i but
i have to
because this is all about defending
women's sports they say or it's about
encouraging women well
what is that exactly
and it's it's kind of interesting timing
that now they've decided to come out uh
about women's sports when there is only
one threat against women's sports and
it's from the trans agenda there are no
other threats
but we can assume that cracker jill is
uh they're not trying to make any
statement about that we can assume that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated